my next guest is the man behind the blog
squad his youtube channel has amassed
more than 7
billion views please welcome back to the
show
david dobrik everybody what's up man how
are you doing
good how are you doing i'm doing all
right um
last time you were on the show you
mentioned that you could actually see
our studio and hogwarts from your house
can you i did i did say that you want to
see right now yes i do
david perfect timing now they're both
stuck at the head i have no choice
yeah can you wait by the way oh actually
oh wait you're not at your studio where
are you
well i'm out of fake city they built in
our living room
so it's like a fake little studio oh my
gosh you really are you can see
that's so crazy but that's hogwarts and
then your studio is right
there oh my gosh you're so close
that's why i'm bummed out that i was
only invited once i could have come by
at any second
i know you're only invited once uh well
we didn't even get through our first
season before having to
pandemic it up and shoot from my house
so how is it shooting from your house
you know what it was hard when we were
in montana we were i was there for like
two a little over two months and i
didn't know we were gonna have to work
from there at first we left so like it
was
very hard because the internet is not
great
um but uh but it ended up i'm back in
l.a now in our
house so they built a little studio so
it's fine now um awesome
how's your quarantine been ah i don't
know it's
it's it's kind of like it's the same
thing every day it's literally just
it's i play so many video games and it's
it's the worst i
i'm just become i'm becoming like my 16
year old self i think
like i'm just like an incredible
homebody and like my friends around me
are now realizing like wow he
really he really likes staying inside
and just being sheltered
i just i do not i don't i don't
communicate with anybody i'm literally
just in my room
just um playing video games but it's fun
so um
you last time you were on um you met
octavia spencer
yeah so have you seen her since oh my
god i
first off i cannot say more positive
things about a person in octavia spencer
i
i i had no idea i i had no idea i was
just gonna completely fall in love with
her i
i ran into her at um it was like an
oscars party or something i don't know
how i got in but i was there and it was
like a bun
it was a bunch of different actors and
um and octavia was there
like in a group with like some pretty
big actors
like like big actors and and i was like
okay
i'm gonna go in i'm gonna say hi to
activity i'm gonna seem so cool because
we know each other
so i go in and and i say hi to her she
says hi she gives me a hug it's like
it's like
best friends reunited um and i'm like
this is going great and
then like i you know i talk to the other
actors there and i'm like i'm like i'm
like really flowing like my conversation
is going right now like i'm doing a good
job
so i'm like wow i'm probably gonna get
like a big movie deal after this this is
nuts
i'm networking king and then as i and i
say goodbye to octavia and i'm walking
away
and one of one of the actors calls me
over and goes hey can you come here
first
second and i'm like oh my god this is my
big break
and and he goes and he goes he whispers
in my ear and he goes
uh your fly is down put your zipper up
oh no oh
yeah that's the worst the entire time i
thought i was being so cool
i had my fly down the entire time that
is like my life in a nutshell
it's the worst that's awesome you guys
are laughing so much and it's because
they were laughing at me
i know well they probably weren't
everybody has stuff like that that
happens but
you know i know i know well though that
they at least told you i hate it
it's the best it takes a lot of courage
to tell somebody
especially when like like when i i
actually never have the courage to tell
anybody like when my friend has food on
their mouth or like somebody i don't
know like there's food on their mouth
i have such a hard time going hey get
the food i don't know why but it's such
an embarrassing car i am the first
person to tell you if you have a booger
your pants are unzipped something's
happening
first person i have no because i want
people to tell me because
i mean obviously we're all human and
stuff happens right right right
but yeah burgers always yeah natalie my
friend my assistant like literally
always tells me i have a booger
association
yeah i'm just like you got something get
it and i'm like you know yeah
but it's the booger it's fine we'll move
on it'll be fine um are you a big online
shopper
um yeah oh my god yeah i've been getting
a bunch of things from um
so i'm on tick tock a lot let me let me
show you a thing i bought on tick tock
okay here okay so these are these are um
these are two things i recently bought
from tick tock
so this is like uh like a pocket like
sword type of thing
so like look it fits in my pocket like a
favor like
like a lightsaber kind of but
but watch so like when i'm under attack
i can just throw it up
not max i'm never in danger
anymore kelly i just have this but do
you know how to use it
not yet not yet but my instructor's
coming right after this call and then i
have
i have this which is really cool you put
like you put your quarter here
and then it takes a little bit
then the panda comes thank you oh
normally he takes the thing in but
he's shy oh my gosh that's something
we've been on a talk show
i just love how he creeps up like yeah
but there's
there's a lot of fun stupid things you
could buy on the internet which i kind
of just been doing because of quarantine
so
obviously what else are we doing other
than what right
you